this episode of congratulations is
brought to you by the cash app you
already know the cash app is the number
one finance app but did you realize that
you can get the most powerful debit card
in the world with the cash apps cash
card just select a boost in your cash
app swipe the cash card and save 10% or
more at Whole Foods Shake Shack Chipotle
taco bell chick-fil-a and all coffee
shops around the country download the
cash app for free on the App Store or
Google Play market this episode of
congratulations is all taubira also
brought to you by simple contacts get
$20 off your contacts at simple contacts
calm / Congrats or enter congrats at
checkout hey guys what's up it's episode
97 we're closing in on episode 100 we
tried to get John Claude Van Damme for
episode 100 and he said no so I don't
know what its gonna be and may just be
me and Oso 200 we may have a special
thing I'm not sure you know I don't know
what we're gonna do but one thing's for
sure it's gonna be [ __ ] gully as [ __ ]
cuz we're always going I have a bunch of
dates coming up in Fresno tour I have a
show coming up in Fresno in two weeks
and I have a show coming up in
Bakersfield in two weeks - follow the
leader tours coming and San Antonio and
Austin and st. Louis and somewhere in
Kentucky and I don't know so go get your
tickets they're selling out some of them
already are sold out so that's what's up
and then also just announced today
Netflix my Netflix special will be
coming out January 1st
it's called comedian it's a kind of a
chunk of comedians that they're
releasing is called comedians of the
world and it's awesome I'm excited to be
a part of it it's half an hour I'm
trying to do these half-hour specials
now man I want to do half hour
because it's just like easier and people
will feel people to feel watching more
the hours are just like so I mean
they're just long and everyone that
they're just so many of them half hours
is just boom you just watch if you want
to watch you're a fan of the guy and
also if you're not a fan of the guy you
don't know about the guy and you just
want it's a half hour [ __ ] it I'll play
it so January 1st cure your hangover
with me comedians of the world only on
Netflix yeah so and you know Netflix is
cool because it doesn't have commercials
and you don't have to [ __ ]
fast-forward through the commercials and
all that [ __ ] but you know that you know
that already because it's because it's
2018 and Netflix has been around for a
while speaking of a commercials how come
they can't make a how come they I swear
to God and I've probably seen almost all
of them why can't they make a funny guy
coke commercial yet every Geico
commercial is has not been funny and I
want to come out and I'm coming out on
the limb saying it because I understand
I'm not trying to be a hater but like
what is the deal dude Geico what's the
deal that whole [ __ ] it they're like
so overwritten and like the guy the one
with the robe the new one with the
aerobics guy where he's just like doing
aerobics in the in the chair and he's
like getting Geico is easy is this just
as easy as doing aerobics in a chair and
he's like in this class doing the the
aerobics in it recliner have you seen it
it's just not it's just like come on
what this is what you thought of you
tried so hard to think of some [ __ ] and
this is what you thought you tried too
hard I'm telling you man these
commercials were the guys just sitting
in that chair telling you about the
product those are the best way to go man
why are you trying to make a commercial
glossy why are you trying to do that
just [ __ ] say what you got to say in
the commercial we don't wanna watch the
[ __ ] commercials anyway why are you
trying to make it funnier trying to get
all these comedy writers and [ __ ]
they're just so bad all these come to
all of them number the one where the guy
was doing the robot and then the lizard
what's up with the lizard dude see yeah
the [ __ ] lizard is stupid
by do they still use the lizard anymore
it's so bad
this is me watching a Geico commercial
am i watching a Geico commercial or am i
watching a [ __ ] documentary gecko
dude even worse that it's a gecko
you know like oh like oh it's a gecko oh
it's so odes oh we're being silly it's
the people know what a lizard is but a
gecko how hilarious that is dude get out
of here man no more the guy doing the
robot that was the worst one and then
the hey I got a good punch is that isn't
that the one that got a good news oh
yeah I saved a lot of money of certain
car insurance oh that was the only those
are the only ones that are passable is
that every ha this one the Geico robot
guy this would I want to play it on the
[ __ ] thing actually if the internet
will allow it because we've been having
some technical difficulties this was
that
yeah Geico this is the one Geico robot
commercial gonna have somebody views
gonna piss me off here we go here it is
at geico.com you can get free rate
quotes and handle all your car insurance
needs online but we like to make it
interesting here's an idea we received
via email yo I think your webs look
here's the thing man they obviously told
this guy we want you to be so still we
want you to be no emotion we want you to
just read it because that's the
funniness of it and what they did was
they [ __ ] up dude you know what I used
to talk about this [ __ ] when people god
how do I explain this this is what I
think this is so hard to explain I
explained it to my mom once and it
worked but I can't I don't think I can
do it to the billions of you that are
listening right now to the billions of
billions people like okay deadpan comedy
deadpan is like the absence of making a
face it's not making a non face and
that's what this guys doing
this drives me nuts is when like well
nothing's going on and you're acting
like nothing's going on if nothing's
going on
nothing's going on you don't have to act
like nothing's going on and that's what
this guys doing and that kind of comedy
drives me more nuts than any other
comedy like the whole [ __ ] talking
head where everyone's so awkward you
know every every show in like 2010 was
like the talking heads like well I don't
know what's up with that guy and then
they would be like um [ __ ] that dude
[ __ ] that comedy if nothing's going on
nothing's going on
stop acting awkward dude I that kind of
cut that not a comedy drives me nuts I'd
rather listen to a [ __ ] comedy about
farts and shits and coming in and and
and all sorts of stuff I'd rather bro
comedy i dude it this cut was nothing to
see here nothing going on that kind of
comedy is the worst [ __ ] dude here
here's an idea we received via email yo
I think your website would be too bomb
if you had the gecko do the robot
okay so the geckos doing the robot now
for some reason they thought that was
funny and now he's doing the robot guy
go 15 minutes could see no reason why
cuz it's just silly no it's not dude you
gotta [ __ ] go further a Geico or
don't try so hard rather this was in
2004 when nothing was funny here uh how
many hits does even have 863 views [ __ ]
eeeh the most fail and ass [ __ ] was
the caveman one funny that might have
been funny no I don't know I feel like
[ __ ] somebody I know is in one of
those and maybe it was funny anyway
yeah Geico get it together dude I know I
get it people don't give a [ __ ] mm-hmm
and people are just like idiots and just
like oh I saw a guy call before I'll get
the [ __ ] thing they probably have a
successful business obviously but just
like get out of here um commercials just
as a whole lady they gotta go I remember
this one dude this one was bad too dude
could switching to Geico really save you
15% or more on car insurance
he said too tall Jones too tall oh my
god dude
and now they're trying to measure a guy
who I guess is head to toe Jones and
he's too tall and then the thing broke
oh oh there's a there's that awkward
comedy 15 minutes I go what I do with
this
oh god oh it's so [ __ ] bad dude we'll
see another one this is a now I'm and I
[ __ ] wow I feel good hating right now
or could switching to Geico really save
you fifteen percent or more on car
insurance
there we go just Johnny Daniel's play a
mean fiddle and John again is playing a
mean fiddle I guess
[Music]
this is what is supposed to be funny so
how you do it son Geico 15 minutes I
would be fine car insurance watching the
Geico really save you fifteen percent or
more on car insurance there's a ten
pound bag of flour make a really big
biscuit Oh cringe dude could switching
to Geico really save you fifteen quick I
mother [ __ ] assurance the cavemen
invent fire good
I mean who what kind of high
[ __ ] thought about this could
switching to Geico save you 15% on your
car insurance
his Johnny big dicks dick big and then
Johnny's just sitting there with his
dick over his shoulders [ __ ] stroking
it off
just calming so hard that's a Geico
commercial Kajaani it could switching to
Geico really save you 15% on your car
insurance is Johnny big dicks dick too
big and then he's just like and then
it's playing [ __ ] he's just like this
jerking his dick off over his shoulder
and then it goes in the back wall that's
that to me that's the then I'm a gone
buying I call immediately
no no it's blurred its plorts all over
the [ __ ] guy doing the robot in that
old commercial it breaks through the
wall and it makes him and it's real and
it's real [ __ ] jizz they use from
guys from guys Co idiot ah yeah I don't
know dude I just like come on get it
together try harder and also try less
that's the thing yeah but I just saw a
guy coke commercial and that's what was
really getting me going the the [ __ ]
here's another thing that sucks wow this
I don't mean to be you a hater and I'm
gonna talk about stuff I like maybe I
should talk about stuff I like now now
[ __ ] it I'm on a roll here oh man I
don't know if I'm on a roll but here we
go
Apple Maps is the worst app there is
okay listen
Apple you're good you got all the [ __ ]
going on hey if I talk about Gucci if I
say to my friends hey I got I like Gucci
then I [ __ ] start getting ads for
Gucci okay if that happens then don't
make me take a left into a lake
dude Apple Maps [ __ ] sucks it's so
bad
hey ways you kill it thank you ways
Apple Macs
Apple Apple Maps you [ __ ] suck [ __ ]
you [ __ ]
if Apple Maps had a [ __ ] I would [ __ ]
her Apple maps in the app did you know
by the way did you notice this in the
Apple maps doesn't how about when you're
walking when you take Apple Maps and you
and you and you decide to walk cuz
you're in the city you haven't been to I
mean I'm like this all the time and then
you have to walk seven blocks for it to
catch up to you and to keep and and and
you're like oh it says you're in the
middle of a [ __ ] park and you're like
on just sixth Street and you're like
come on man and you're trying you're
looking at your phone like an idiot try
to walk around to get the Apple max map
caught up with your [ __ ] how does Apple
let this one not be the [ __ ] when all
the other apps are the [ __ ] ever getting
lost I'm sure somebody's gotten lost and
beaten the [ __ ] out of cuz the Apple
maps I'm sure they're like I think we'll
go left here and then you go into like a
terrible neighborhood and then you get
beat the [ __ ] out of and someone steals
your iPhone all cuz the Apple maps I
want that to happen I will sue them I'm
gonna sue you Apple maps you're gonna
take me left into another bad knit into
a bad neighborhood and I'm gonna sue you
Apple Maps that's how it's gonna go
god it's
so it's such a weird you know
firstworldproblems I get I've come with
my Geico commercials and Apple Maps but
come on
you know this is your job that's the
thing when I got older when I got
successful at my job that's when I
started getting pissed off that people
couldn't be doing their jobs right cuz
they'll do when I go on stage I either
kill it or or I'm really trying I'm
working hard you know but people like
when when it's like when you're not
doing your job
and I get it not everybody has the job
that they want and they don't they're
not afforded the opportunities that I
was in my life but like man what certain
to Geico really save you 15% on your car
insurance that guy was a guy from was
that old Edie Edie
who's the guy the 90s guy brothers
McMullen Edie ed Byrnes yeah he was he
was in that movie he was always in he'd
played a Ed Burns brother always consoie
chewing the gut and then he was to
switching to Geico there were a movie
called brothers McMullen that was like
big in the 90s and it became a bigger it
became a it like kind of launched ed
Byrnes career it burns the cool actor
everything it's how those guys like
Colin's just like talks like this and
he's always like he's like Bruce Willis
but like more handsome and he's all like
yeah give a ship he's like yeah yeah
yeah yeah I don't like you but I don't
give a [ __ ] about it like that kind of
guy you know and I'm I don't want to
[ __ ] you saying he's talking like this I
think he's like so New York but he was
so like he looks like a guy that would
like drug you and rape you but he didn't
he know he probably never did that
because he's looking to probably a good
guy and he's [ __ ] super handsome did
I just [ __ ] love that guy I still do
but he I haven't seen him in some [ __ ]
lately he I mean Finbarr he played Barry
Finbar McMullen wife in bar anyway
he it was it was a brother mom and then
he and then was I trying gonna say about
him though oh yeah and then he did a
movie called some other the Geico guys
named Michael mcloon anyway the Ed Burns
did a movie called what was the movie
where he did all we do in the group it's
such a we would make fun you know we
make fun of everything in my group text
and we were and he has there's a movie
that begins is the worst beginning to
any movie ever and he was in it and he's
[ __ ] dead it on the on the concrete
and it's an overhead shot of him and
he's just laying down dead and the
voiceover and it's Edie burns
unmistakable voice and he says some dead
right I don't remember what movie that
was but it was so I was in the theater I
think it was confidence I was in the
theater and it starts and he and he
shows his body and he says saw him dead
right and I was just like that's it I'm
done watching movies you don't have to
hook us so hard
constructing the geico what's worse
being in the movie King them being in
the commercials come switching to Geico
really save you 15% on your car
insurance then had burns do a movie that
starts out with an overhead shot of him
dead and then him voice over it saying
so I'm dead right so I'm dead right this
is the beginning so I'm dead
fade in it black it's black first and he
says so I'm dead and then it says dump
dumpsters overflow with the day's
garbage a pillar of steam rises from an
underground great it's the dark it's the
dark place between buildings that a
reasonable person avoids do die every
time I write a script and I send it to
my agents and managers to see what they
think of it they're always like like I
don't do this [ __ ] like this [ __ ]
[ __ ] about scripts where they're like
dumpsters overflow with the day's
garbage a pillar of steam rises from an
underground great this is the dark blue
dude just shoot the [ __ ] thing it's
not a novel and they're always like yeah
but describe it
I'm like nah if I was gonna write this
I'd be like oh boys over so I'm dead it
would be black so I'm dead three black
voiceover Jake so I'm dead
fade in back-alley night Jake's dead
more voiceover and I think it's because
there's a redhead uh so I'm dead right
and I think it's because of this redhead
hey if you're dead you're dead you're
not thinking yeah dude the day the
overflows with the day's garbage and
then when you're gonna go shoot it you
don't think about that well there's
day's garbage in the thing but you
always have like that the guy who does
the set dressing that's like well it
says his old floor with the gay today's
garbage so he brought a bunch of garbage
on the thing if you want and the
directors like you don't give a [ __ ]
about that the director doesn't give a
[ __ ] about that [ __ ] how do they write
this [ __ ] dude I was watching two movies
on the plane I was watching Furious 7
which by the way Fast and the Furious I
guess is the first one go to the catalog
fast and furious there's fast and
furious and then there's like too fast
too furious the titles of these Fast and
Furious movies The Fast and the Furious
first one number two 2 fast 2 furious
okay number three The Fast and the
Furious okay
the fastener here is Tokyo Drift okay
well first of all the first was called
The Fast and Furious and the third was
called The Fast and the Furious
Tokyo Drift okay then the fourth one is
fast and furious
okay then the fifth one is Fast Five
okay then the sixth one is Fast and
Furious 6 okay well just go with one
through five then for the first ones man
now you're confusing the [ __ ] out of us
now you go with the [ __ ] numeric
value at the end now the the the the the
one after that Furious 7
so they're not fast anymore they're just
mad then the fate of the Furious K
Furious 7 was the one I saw and I know I
talked about this on the podcast before
too
every character is the same character in
all of those movies they're all like
this not today
this is [ __ ] Jason Statham it doesn't
matter who they are in the movie Jason
Statham not today the rock not today
[ __ ] Tyrese not today
Ludacris oh not today the chick the
[ __ ] Michelle Rodriguez not today
Ronda Rousey not today they're all not
today [ __ ] how the [ __ ] can you
keep writing not today in characters in
the movie the movie should just be
called not today dude it's so you
thought you got me not today I'm taking
you in not today and now they're doing
Hobbes and Shaw with [ __ ] Jason
Statham and the rock dude that franchise
is unbelievable they drive through
buildings they go to [ __ ] Vin Diesel
dude Vin [ __ ] Diesel brow not today
that's the Vin Diesel doing it Vin
Diesel
how can people say Vin Diesel is jacked
is he I've never seen him with his shirt
off in the movies is he jacked I don't
know I feel like Vin Diesel is the kind
of guy that holds his penis when he
takes a dump dude and he's just and
they're just like are you gonna [ __ ]
piss and he's just like not today then
these is the kind of guy that if you're
at craft service and you go to take the
last piece of cheesecake he tries to
beat you to it
cuz it's he's like but and he goes nut
today cuz he's on I mean then there's
fast and furious 9 and then it's fast
and furious 10 these movies are just
when Ludacris fights a bad guy in the
movie I'm just like dude I want to [ __ ]
all over myself it's so funny
why are we pretending that Ludacris is a
badass you know first of all he's the
guy who stays in the van anyway why
can't they all fight do they all go to
the [ __ ] marshal oh well they can all
drive and they can all fight God dude
Ludacris there's nothing more 90s and
2000 there's nothing more 2000s than
ludicrous there's nothing more 2000s
than ludicrous ah if you google 2003
Ludacris comes up go ahead
Ludacris is [ __ ] Cadillac grills
Cadillac Spears Oh watch out my Cadillac
grills Cadillac Mills Cadillac Hills
Oh watch out my Cadillac drills Cadillac
rails Cadillac bills and white kids were
just like [ __ ] yeah dude
Cadillac thrills Cadillac thrills huh
Oh watch how my Cadillac brill's good
dude when they [ __ ] were like when
they got when they got Ludacris was like
for fast and furious they're like can
you do this movie and he was like oh
it's about cars hell yeah
can I Drive a cadillac grills cadillac
Brill's
Cadillac Friel in the agents I come
Ludacris calm down calm down
excuse me calm down okay I'm just
excited and who's like woo you we don't
know if it's gonna be a Cadillac who is
that what I hope it's a Cadillac frailes
and the agents like I came what do you
want to do it or why it's like sure
rails and then
help it sure I'll do it Cadillac Brill
okay alright well we'll tell him yes and
then he got unset and they were like hey
so here's the car he's like what the
[ __ ] that's not a Cadillac brill's
Cadillac frills like yeah but listen
we're paying you [ __ ] $1,000,000 to
do this movie well frills okay I'll do
it
drills I can I hold this Cadillac emblem
in my pocket
it's 2001 when I shot fast and furious
I can't believe in two years it's gonna
be 2003 and that's basically what I am
chicken and beer Cadillac frills then he
have the [ __ ] thing called chicken
and beer the the type of lazy lazy who
would have thought that the guy who runs
Cadillac grills with Cadillac spills
would name his title with named his
album chicken and beer Cadillac grills
Cadillac meals check out the all my
Cadillac spills matter of fact Kenny
pink Cadillacs kill so check out the HOS
my Cadillac fails I mean just 20 inch
wide 20 inches high oh don't you like
about 28 ride 20 inch ride so it's when
I um it's a con hey you mind if I got a
ride hoping for American 20 inch PI's
early l'olam here we go the candy genius
annotation the candy quote-unquote paint
job high gloss finish on his Cadillac is
impressive hence he ends up filling lots
of women with his Cadillac in the name
parentheses nickname for his penis
ah yeah yeah okay because this dick is
Cadillac I mean dude pretty ass clothes
pretty ass
toes oh how I love these pretty ass hoes
disrespectful dude I can't believe that
is a song it bangs though doesn't it
I just [ __ ] it's also why is he
screaming dude the people in the [ __ ]
in the thing were just like oh god I so
loud okay well it's what he does and
then he was in [ __ ] fast and furious
and he dude those guys in that franchise
luck to the [ __ ] out man if Vin Diesel
Ludacris if they weren't in that
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] would they be
doing romantic comedies and no no way
dude I want to talk to you guys about
SeatGeek
getting tickets online can be far too
complicated with hundreds of sites and
varying levels of reliability it's hard
to know who to trust
that's why SeatGeek is the way to go
seat geek pulls millions of tickets into
one place so you can easily find the
seats you want for a price you're
willing to pay there's nothing quite
like being there in person and seat geek
will get you closer to the action for a
great value seat geek is designed to
make your ticket buying experience
easier than ever by searching multiple
ticket sites and grading every ticket
based on value seat geek helps you
immediately identify the best seats that
fit your budget plus every purchase is
fully guaranteed so you can shop for
tickets on SeatGeek with confidence make
seat geek your go-to ticket source for
everything from sports and concerts to
comedy and theater I have this up in my
phone and it comes in handy trust me
it's awesome I I've used it before so
best of all my listeners get $10 off
their first seat geek purchase just
download the seat geek app and enter
promo code congrats today that's Pro
Mode code congrats for $10 off your
first seat geek purchase seat geek
life's an event we have the tickets goat
now I'm a shoe guy if you're buying
sneakers online
there's more than a coin flips chance
that the shoe you're looking for or that
you're looking at is fake how can you be
sure it's real don't go on eBay you do
this it's gonna come to you it's gonna
be fake you're gonna know when you get
it or if you don't know then they're
gonna you're gonna wear it and people
are gonna see it they're gonna be like
oh that's a fake they're gonna be
embarrassed
goat calm is the safest way to buy and
sell authentic sneakers online they're
the largest marketplace in the world for
authentic Easy's Jordans and over
600,000 sneaker listings they've made
the whole process frictionless and
trustworthy every detail is inspected
from the stitching and color to the size
and weight Goat certifies that every
pair of sneakers on their site matches
exact factory specifications with over
half a million sneakers on the platform
and 10 million users come on you're not
gonna find a better place
it's 100% authentic sneakers everywhere
more than anywhere else find the perfect
100% authentic sneaker at Goat calm
slash Congrats
that's goat comm slash code plus you'll
also be supporting our show
goat calm slash Congrats plus you'll
also be supporting our show but you've
got to go right now before the sneakers
you want are gone because you know they
go fast
when you go to goat comm / Congrats
spelled Geo 80 comm / Congrats it's
great I just got the Yeezy I have an
idiot dude I got someone I got the new
salt 500 salt 500 and I got the boots I
got the easy boots with the [ __ ] the
duck caramel and then I got the other
boots they were all [ __ ] sold out the
boots I wanted so I got the the other
ones some other ones that are like
probably I'm not gonna wear that much I
don't know man
he's crazy but he does he he he kills it
with the [ __ ] no not those he kills
it with the with the fashion dude anyway
I'm just kind of like look at the hose
my Cadillac spills you know I'm talking
about that's just kind of like my thing
those are the ones I got yeah dude I'm
gonna be [ __ ] futuristic with those um
I know I say this but ludicrous oh he
was mad at me at the peeper roast it's
funny he got mad at me for something
Jeff Ross said okay cool
he's like man you shouldn't have said
that I was like why what say what he was
like the thing about Paul Walker I was
like oh I didn't
he was like yeah you did and I was like
no I didn't he was like yeah you did no
I was like okay I didn't want to be like
it was Jeff Ross and throw Jeff Ross
under the bus but Ludacris wore
sunglasses the whole time during the
roast they tried to [ __ ] you can't do
stand-up or some guys you have to have
self-awareness dude Tyrese in that movie
holy for [ __ ] sake that [ __ ] the
goddamn movie that [ __ ] goddamn movie
Jesus Christ Tyrese in that movie
there's one part in that movie where
it's just so glaringly apparent that
Tyrese doesn't get how to make a joke
they're doing all this [ __ ] on the
computer and it's like we got a hack
into the thing and then that and this
that and this that thing and the line
tyreese's line is can I check my email
and the funny way to do that
R&B singer is to know that you can't
check your email on that to know that
it's a you're making a joke as the
character and to know you're just given
the guy's some [ __ ] but Tyrese said
the line like he really wanted to check
his email and then did the awkward
comedy thing like we was like oh I can't
dude it was so hurt it hurt me man like
can I check my mallet you like y'all got
your maimie on and then have them be
like [ __ ] you [ __ ] you man and you
know you can't but the guy dude I can't
this movie where Tyrese and Ludacris are
in a suit and Ludacris's facial hair is
just so perfect that house sad what
happened was [ __ ] Paul Walker Jesus
Christ Paul Walker I I liked him cuz I
like he was like reminding me account of
Reeves a little bit anyway whatever sad
[ __ ] yeah so uh anyway that said about
those movies I guess I know how long
we're gonna talk about that [ __ ]
movie I've already also talked about on
the podcast did you guys hear about this
[ __ ] idiot this lady that was like
mad that first of all let me go on state
let me go on stage let me go on record
by saying the whole ABCDE name thing
where the lady was on the flight and the
daughter's name was as it is pronounced
AB City I guess which you know come on
down to AB City tired of your gut we've
got [ __ ] exercise for days
her name was absentee spelled ABCDE by
the way uh if I meet that girl I'm not
pronouncing it that way I'm going oh hi
ABCD or what I'm just calling her a
Karen or some [ __ ] anyway the Southwest
Airlines employee posted making fun of
this girl and her ticket which is
[ __ ] stupid and atrocious and you
deserve to get fired because you can't
use you can't post [ __ ] like that so let
me just go on record and say that lady
or that man whoever did that is a [ __ ]
and they deserve to be fired ok but the
lady the mother who named her daughter
is upset at the airline place for
laughing at the name now look you named
your kid
ABCDE so you did that for attention
period that's it you did it for
attention you're going to get the
attention
the thing about attention is you're not
in control of the attention or the kind
or style of attention you're going to
get because other people have other
Minds so don't say someone is name
shaming your daughter when you named
your daughter a shameful name but you
know that or you're a [ __ ] dunce so
which is it ABCDE
- you know that secretly and you're a
[ __ ] liar or are you a dunce because
it's one or the other I mean dude you
know ABCDE and she had a little also she
had another kid just eat the f G H I J I
can't do it if it's not murder whatever
it isn't the next five Jeff Kedah Jeff
Kouga is her last name Jeff Kurr ernet
our next son or daughter yeah these
people just live willy-nilly thinking
thinking that they can't deal with any
ripples are you why Riddick why [ __ ]
have your daughter name that life's hard
enough
her name is gonna be [ __ ] ABCDE her
whole life no ab city no no it's
absentee it's actually absentee her
whole life it's such a white thing to do
to do that [ __ ] it's so funny like that
white people and black people do the
same [ __ ] only with black people it's
like Shaniqua or Kwan's l and it's like
then with with white people it's Apple
and AB City
like you it's the same [ __ ] you know god
is a is jay-z and Beyonce are they on
tour that's a tour I just like I think
it's weird when a guy and a girl work
together on it as artists and then they
go on tour together I don't know there's
something about me that just doesn't
like I don't want to see that I would
never do that you know like I would
never be I mean look it's it's money for
them I guess but they're ready have all
the money so it's just weird to be like
yeah we on stage and we we doing this
but also we [ __ ] sometimes and we love
each other and we made a kid we made
some kids anyway what's that crazy and
Dane Dane ain't
neh-neh-neh-neh-neh-neh-neh
Oh Oh coming up oh oh oh oh we made a
kid
oh oh oh did it twice and it's not just
business we love each other
Oh ladies and gentlemen welcome our
special guest somebody that we had a
menage tois with ladies and gentlemen
please welcome our daughters they're
gonna come out to and our maid you want
me to clean anything here's a towel mr.
jay-z oh oh oh oh you sweaty Beyonce oh
I just I'd like if they [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know if you make love it's not even
about [ __ ] it's about loving that's
the thing like if you [ __ ] the tour's
over I guess but if you were like if
you're like you know if you just love
how the [ __ ] Cadillac spills all your
hoes you know and you just want to smash
your background dancers that's fine but
the second you love them and you're like
yeah you know we love each other I gave
her some really nice gifts last
Christmas like it doesn't it's like okay
what are you what are you doing here
yeah I don't know why that bothers me
but it does like be like thinking about
Beyonce bringing her man on tour to do
this like thinking about jay-z bringing
her his girl on tour it's like what do
you I mean I get it grow with your your
audience and your crowd and you have a
family now and [ __ ] like that I don't
know man it's just weird I haven't even
listened to that album yet I don't know
if I will or what but uh Beyonce coming
out with every song is about like how
it's hard for women and hard for all the
[ __ ] I would love to know how it's hard
for Beyonce by the way right now I would
love to know how hard it is for Beyonce
I won't Beyonce to make the real songs
that a real heart like she's like mmm my
fourth maid was sick also like that
whole thing where they thought jay-z
cheated on her and then [ __ ] she made
the song about how he cheated on her and
[ __ ] did that really happen you know did
that really happen did one time I was
doing a [ __ ] I was doing a like this
robot bit I was with two buddies and I
was doing this robot bit where I was
pretending I was this robot it was in my
TV room house pretend I was doing his
robot and I was pretending like I was
like it was the dumbest bit I was just
acting out me doing stand-up like
reading like like looking for like
chicks and the audience and I'm and I
was like doing stand-up and I was like
pretending to lock in on faces and being
like age and the age would come up and I
was pretending like I was [ __ ] like
the age would come up and the and
and like like it was like a sexist robot
bit I was doing like where I was on
stage doing that [ __ ] and I kept on
being like lock in little potential mate
potential and I was it would type out or
[ __ ] the age and all the [ __ ] like
Robocop does in those movies and my
buddy was laughing and my other buddy
was texting on the phone not paying
attention and then my buddy stops
texting and and said I don't a to this
day I don't know what he meant but he
said did that really happen and I
[ __ ] I absolutely let we did we
laughed for so what we did we were like
what do you mean I said
no Sam was I really a robot for a little
bit I still don't know what he meant but
we [ __ ] cried laughing is my buddy
Sam um well that wasn't worth saying on
the podcast but whatever at least you
know a little bit about my life tipsy
elves everyone needs an ugly Christmas
sweater this time of year deck the halls
with one of tipsy elves --is outrageous
Christmas sweater designs they're
one-of-a-kind seriously high quality and
crazy comfortable too after you pick one
up or five of your favorite ugly
sweaters check out some of their other
crazy holiday attire for men they got
stylish Christmas suits for the
classiest of holiday gentlemen
interactive sweaters beer pong cornhole
drinking game darts so Uncle Bob can
relive his college glory days at family
dinner and even hilarious themed teas
and awesome cozy onesies for women
holiday dresses so you can get down with
your bad elf huh i catching leggings so
you can strike a festive yoga pose or
lounge around with a cup of spiked
eggnog and tease that sleigh and cute
comfy onesies
they got ski suits even for when you're
threading some snow this holiday season
you won't find more hilariously awesome
designs anywhere else so be sure to
order from tipsy elves in time for your
ugly Christmas sweater party and right
now my listeners get 20% off tipsy elves
calm when you use my code Congrats at
checkout that's 20% off anything you
order on the site go to tipsy elves comm
and enter my code Congrats at checkout
to get your 20% site-wide discount cash
app you already know the cash app is
the number one app in finance but did
you realize that you can get one of the
most powerful debit cards in the world
with the cash apps cash card the cash
card comes with boosts a feature you
can't get anywhere else because cash app
event invented it just select a boost in
your cash app swipe the cash card and
save 10% or more at Whole Foods Shake
Shack Chipotle Taco Bell chick-fil-a and
all coffee shops around the country the
coffee shop boost takes $1 off at any
coffee shop including Dunkin and
Starbucks drink 100 cups a year save
$100 it's that simple and I just wanted
to prove to you how good I am at math
become a part of the greatest rewards
program ever and download the cash app
now that's the number one app for a
reason and the cash card is the only
debit card with boosts and of course
when you download the cash app and enter
the referral code Congrats
you'll receive $5 and the cash app will
send $5 2 times up Legal Defense Fund
visit the App Store or Google Play
market and download the cash out so yeah
that's it I don't know how I was looking
I was we were walking around the mall in
Boston I'm so cold my opener by the way
is like he's this is how like you know
what I you know what actually I don't
understand people something he said like
somebody came up to him once and he was
like hey man did you hear D'Elia did you
hear Santino and I did Andrew Santino's
podcast whiskey ginger and they were
like did you hear Santino and and Chris
talked about you on their podcast and he
was like no and he was like aw man he
they were really talking [ __ ] about you
like I don't understand obviously I love
my opener and I think he's hilarious I
don't understand how somebody could come
to my show this was after a show this
happened they said I don't understand
how somebody could come to my show
seemingly get my humor have a great time
and then actually think I was talking
[ __ ] about my opener in
like how do you get my humor come to a
show but then not understand I'm joking
about that that that blows my mind it's
so weird
do you get it or not you in this cult or
what because if not what the [ __ ] is
your nose doing facing my nose turn
round get bent I'm inside you right hey
Chris is talking [ __ ] about what's give
you well what the heck let's give me a
mile up I'm inside you why are you also
ratting me out you dick it's free conch
you could do whatever you want but why
are you ratting out the cult leader what
the [ __ ] you a part of this or not you
you know what dude I just realized
you're a mark ass [ __ ] dude
that's what I realized the [ __ ] are you
gonna do that kind of my show and then
rap me the [ __ ] out you mark ass [ __ ]
that's that's crazy dude well you know
what we should do is just have
Craigslist ad that's those are fun let's
do those did you see the [ __ ] Liam
Neeson thing that they did on my
Instagram i reposted it man that [ __ ]
was funny to me um here we go alright
we're gonna do these a lot more now I
like these they make me laugh the title
on this one is handsome dad type okay do
you mean portly what do you mean ugly
what do you mean a nice haircut I don't
get it anyway you are younger asian guy
cute curious how do you know he's
curious we have a [ __ ] magnifying
glass you are younger eight you are
younger asian guy cute curious nice body
I'm tall hands
successful mentor type hit me up if you
want to get together do not contact me
with unsolicited services or offers I
guess this wasn't a miss connection
right this is just him saying he's a
handsome dad type dude I love her you
show up and it's just like some [ __ ]
gross troglodyte but yeah my opener
weird this is how a dummy was we were in
[ __ ] Boston and he was like and he
was like man I feel like this place is
big how come people don't talk about how
big this place is we were on three
blocks that's it
we walked four blocks maybe to get to a
mall and I was like what do you mean
this place is big he's like I look at it
I was like we didn't go anywhere
what do you just mean the buildings are
big it's like now I just feel like it's
big like what it's definitely as big as
New York what you're not what do you
what are you saying you're just looking
around in your immediate vicinity that's
like just he's like now it's like big
it's like la what did the guys like that
blow my mind anyway here we go go back
to that one this is oh wow the title and
this one is [ __ ] awesome the title in
this one in this Craigslist last list is
Craigslist Craigslist ad is hey bro
come on by again this one here the
subject hey bro come on by today slash
tonight remember when we used to hang on
the DL loved loved your nut that guy has
parents you know that guy was born you
know what I mean
he was born and played with toys when he
was a kid and like chilled out and
watched Barney or like Sesame Street and
now he's like remember when we used to
hang out on the DL loved you're not do
not contact me with unsolicited service
or office by the way if that guy is
saying don't contact me with unsolicited
services or offers then nobody contact
anyone with unsolicited services or
offers cuz that guy seems like a guy who
says remember when you
to come by on the DL loved your nut
seems like he'd probably go for some
unsolicited services or offers like that
guy probably doesn't say no to many ah
dude hey loved your nut bud wow that's
like the gayest thing you could possibly
say here we go well I mean the next one
you know we'll do this one but looking
for my former cleaning lady okay so far
seems pretty innocuous is it the right
word I only had you clean a couple of a
couple times focusing on the kitchen and
bathroom you were super fun and it was
so cool that you were down to clean
topless haha there there who wrote this
M night Shyamalan that took a [ __ ]
weird turn at the end it was amazing to
watch as my apartment got cleaned up
nicely I like how this guy's trying to
write it like he's a it's a novel it was
amazing to watch as my apartment got as
my apartment got cleaned up nicely like
she did it but he's trying to be cute
about it you know hoping to bring you
back in parentheses or just hang out if
you're out there really
oh dude really that blue that's odd
you're down to have a chick come over
and clean your [ __ ] bad parts in your
apartment with her taters out dude you
you're you're up for that are you sure
boy are you laughing at are you up for
that dude that's odd that you
some chick come by clean your house and
with her [ __ ] rudder zap so
disrespectful dude imagine if you were
hooking up with a chick and you took out
her boobs and you thought and you said
out loud oh look at these rudders
ah nice rudders dude there's nothing
more disrespectful than that or if you
tried to say it nicely at a Starbucks
like wow nice rudders and then she's
like what [ __ ] you like whoa
excuse me do not do not contact me
unsolicited services or offers she's
trying to say nice writers here we go
this is gotta be a good one because the
title is clogged the nine inch pipe is
it for plumbing or hmm huh I wonder if
this one's for plumbing or forgetting
your nut out just this is the body dude
I love when they say they're light
skinned by the way it's so funny to me
like that's what's gonna sell you on it
like you're like I don't know but
they're light skinned here we go just a
22 year old light-skinned Latino male
looking for some fun too one oh [ __ ] it
says his phone number which I'm
definitely not gonna say um clogged nine
inch pipe like that guy doesn't jerk off
all the time it's just clogged oh my God
look at the title of this one we work at
UPS case the least sexual title of all
time what's good I think you knew there
at work but I'm the black guy we always
look at each other but you sexy a F we
workday sort what okay let's let me try
to put this in the actual terms what's
good I think you are new at work but I'm
the black guy we Oh anyway
we always look at each other but you're
sexy
we workday sort huh do not contact me
with unsolicited unsolicited services oh
yeah
I used to know a guy that would go to
this donut shop and you would get donuts
and go get a [ __ ] from the lady
behind the counter like later like late
at night when nobody was there
she he'd get doughnuts and eat doughnuts
while they while the lady would who
didn't speak English would would suck
his dick like I think that was this that
was in 2001 - he told me that I think
that was the beginning of the end of the
world you know what I mean like getting
eating first of all eating doughnuts
while getting your you know I mean just
at home is ridiculous but at a [ __ ]
doughnut place you know what I'll get a
jelly uh let me get some sugar doughnuts
and then could I pop behind there and
just have you suck me off or are we
doing that how does that even go how did
that even start I never even thought
about this that guy was funny
obviously I'm not gonna say his name but
I used to do jujitsu with the guy um
okay here's another one this last one
I'll do ride my face is the title right
to it huh different different I like how
they can be sometimes we work at ups and
then sometimes just right to the chase
right my face looking for a woman to
ride my face wearing jeans must be able
to host looking ASAP you know first of
all how I mean wearing jeans gonna
scrape your face up oh wow it's so dudes
interesting the [ __ ] that turns people
on like why wouldn't you want her jeans
off if you were into face riding first
of all because you'd want her jeans off
because of how sex is usually better
naked but this guy gets turned on with
jeans on his face that's like the origin
story of a Batman villain and he's now
he's jean face he's doctor blue jeans
face you know I used to get my jeans
done fit if I had like a button or a
tear in it I used to take him to a place
called doctor blue jeans you know and
they'd always be like make sure your
jeans are washed before you bring them
in and I would never do that and I would
always think oh yeah but I'm not like
I'm not who they're talking about I'm
not disgusting how [ __ ] egotistical
is that how that's what everybody who
does thinks that by the way you could be
a [ __ ] sweaty creased out troll and
just like yeah but they're not talking
about me just was [ __ ] in their jeans
yeah but my shit's clean here doctor
blue jeans I need these I need these
jeans done because they ripped because I
need some girl to sit on my faith about
it AB City dude her name was absent
anyway how about that guy who said that
he was not 16 and he 69 anymore and he
was gonna be legally 20 years younger
and he was like yeah if people can say
they're a man or a woman and they were
born a man or a woman then I can be 49
fo him 69 and he's trying to get it
legally changed his age first of all how
this guy looks exactly how you'd think
he'd look and he's what is he like he's
gotta be like Finnish or Dutch or some
[ __ ] right look at him I mean look at
that guy
there's no way that guy talks like this
hi how you doing there's no ways from
like [ __ ] Nebraska he's gotta be from
Eastern European European ER he's Dutch
Wow
called it okay so he looks so Dutch and
he's just like yeah I'm not going to be
69 anymore I'm going to be 49 to get
young [ __ ]
Wow and he posed for the pic and he's
just like it's on [ __ ] I like
that I like that guy just uprooting the
system that guy just the fact that he's
like yeah oh you're gonna be a woman now
even though you were born a man okay
cool
I'm 20 years younger are we on board no
oh we're not okay well I was on your
side so what the [ __ ] the deal for me
you got to pretend like I'm 49 if I'm
saying you're a guy I mean face riding
you know so uncomfortable also that's
not just what that guy wants he wants to
have sex too you know he should be a
little bit more forthcoming on his
Craigslist ad I feel like a lot of
people well I don't know anyway I got
some dates coming up I got some dates
coming up Fresno Bakersfield Austin San
Antonio Louise Louisville Indianapolis
st. Louis Boulder Colorado Springs Salt
Lake City Madison Milwaukee one of those
is moving to the bigger theater because
we're selling more tickets and we added
a show in Salt Lake City Chicago
Illinois that's sold out in a day we're
gonna add another one later on
um Seattle I think we're gonna add
another one Hamilton Windsor cometh
Ontario Windsor Ontario Kalamazoo
Michigan Anna I'm standing as Valley
Center California anyway the list goes
on
Lexington Cincinnati Columbus Cleveland
Huntington New York and over Albany but
so get your tickets and follow the
leader tour crystal Viacom at Christy
icon and that's that download the cash
app for free on the App Store or Google
Play market and two rewards code
Congrats get $5 give $5 - times up and
download the Krista Lea app so you can
see you go - if you got itunes or
wherever you get apps you can just
download my app chris d'elia type that
in typing Krista Lea and then you could
see the podcast before anybody and see
also other content that I do throughout
the day that I don't post on Instagram
and stuff like that it's the last this
is right this is last day first or is
this from the last one for free domestic
shipping industry no yep and one fire
okay
subscribe
to the YouTube channel and those dent
shirts are being made and they'll be
sent out soon because a thousand have
you got those so you go and get some
merch we got the wouldn't make a dent
shirts and all that [ __ ]
Chris Chris Thalia calm just go have a
visit and have fun you know just have a
[ __ ] blast on my website videos go up
Tuesday's or Wednesdays and I got a new
special coming up I got a new special
coming out on Network January 1st so be
on the lookout for that all right babies
thanks a lot and remember
[Music]